[Musik]
jetzt wo der doofe tram braig ist
erobern die amis wieder unsere herzen im
sturm und als dankeschön baut
deutschland ihnen einen riesigen hafen
für ihr fracking gas der bürgermeister
von uns wird kann es kaum erwarten
der altmaier sagt wir wollen in
deutschland so ein terminal haben ja und
wenn in deutschland so ein teil gebaut
wird dann erst ist unser anspruch dann
soll dieses terminal im bundesbesitz
derweil natürlich wie gesagt er kommt
warum dann kommt aus barock und jeder
euro ist hier blendend angelegt ja ein
maritimer flair durchzieht diese nordsee
perle überall wer dran geglaubt aber wie
immer es gibt diesmal warum ist fracking
schlecht in den usa macht es natürlich
die gesamte gegend kaputt das macht das
wasser kaputt ja noch die leute krank
da kommt das gas von einer kaputten
gegen in eine andere nach wunsch
wir haben neben arme
müllverbrennungsanlage auf der einen
seite haben wir ein kernkraftwerk das
kernkraftwerk das ist quester die haben
zwei fonds gehen tanz 19 profitieren
auch wenn die hoch gehen ja dann ist ins
mittelfeld ist jetzt die frage ob das
ein großer verlust wäre ich bin so der
bundesbürger sie sind das gas tablet
wenn sie also in die luft gehen dann
macht es dann geht die chemie fabrik los
ich als gutes mittlerweile h gift gifte
kommen auf der anderen seite gehen dann
die castoro strahlen dann sage ich als
bringt zwar ein bisschen weh aber danke
ich tu's für die deutsch-amerikanische
freundschaft und weiter so um dass mal
ein bisschen nüchtern politisch
darzustellen und wohlstand in
deutschland politisch darstellen heißt
einfach wir machen einen plan fest
sobald sich verfahren haben hohe
sicherheitsanforderungen er sowohl an
das kernkraftwerk und den abbau des
kampfes um die castor behälter als auch
natürlich an das lng importe da vorne
sind
wieviel castor-transport 20 castoren ja
und wie weit so inhalt etwa 66 400 euro
pro behälter also sozusagen zu 120
tschernobyl hat man genau und daneben
noch die ganze chemie und sowas
unterhalt die sprengkraft von 100 euro
im abo was haben wir alle gegen das
dürfte freundschafts gas auch bauer
stägert der schimpft über erzwungene
probebohrung auf seinem acker wie kann
man nur so bockig sein
wir haben ja uns auch geweigert dass ich
ihr probebohrung macht ja aber wenn das
ministerium kommt um mit 500 euro
zwangsgeld und polizei eskorte hier die
bohrung machen wir ja dann gebe ich nach
ja da ist natürlich auch nicht in dieser
schleswig holsteinischen launische
heftigkeit und dass man so will darf man
nicht und so was ist jetzt macher die
die packen an und dann wird auch mal
loch gebohrt und dann wird einfach mal
geguckt müsste natürlich mit solchen
leuten müsse jetzt nochmal vorlieb
nehmen
hier geht es nicht um ein paar
maulwurfshügel hier geht es um
völkerfreundschaft um geopolitik mann
[Musik]
verstärkt
das fracking hier
wird zusammen mit meinen amerikanischen
freunden hier kopiert das ist jetzt
unser sehr schön und das war's mit dem
acker es lebe die deutsch amerikanische
freundschaft ja wohl jetzt salutieren es
ist soweit
das habe ich bei der bundeswehr gemacht
das mache ich jetzt hier nicht mehr
weiter
[Musik]
hallo leute ich bin's der heute-show
mime hersteller
wenn ihr mehr heißen scheiß und sie
töten - wollt dann abonniert jetzt den
kanal
was zur hölle ist minimal hersteller
[Musik]